how's it going everyone over the years
all the action films we've made and all
the airsoft games we played we've
amassed quite a collection of airsoft
guns we have hundreds of guns and here
are so the ones I think have the best
stories the most unique features are
probably some the coolest airsoft guns
that are out there
classic UMP Counter Strike battlegrounds
one of my favorite designs SMGs mp7 near
and dear to my heart the reason it's so
near and dear to my heart a grenade
launcher which is just basically a giant
shotgun because the airsoft give the
grenades you a little bunch of pellets
and it's just like a large rotary barrel
it's like a revolver for shotgun shells
we're gonna m16 with an underslung
grenade launcher kind of the same deal
you have a normal functioning rifle and
underneath to basically have a giant
shotgun this gun it's a special movie
gun this is light machine gun variant of
a g36 now this gun was used in vGHS over
here with an m14 this guy was using
tether still shoots like a champion
[Music]
now the vector in real life is a gun
that's designed to have very little
recoil because there's a set of weights
here that go downwards when you shoot
that minimize your upwards child an
airsoft gun has the same thing it's
gas-powered they actually have a
mechanism there that slides down and
there's not a lot of kick but you can
feel how it moves and it's a pretty
authentic replica of the real thing now
when a company makes an airsoft gun they
have to license the gun design for the
actual comfort so for a while the
company that makes this gun didn't
actually let people use the license so a
couple of these guns are made and then
they are immediately cut off and they
couldn't make anymore
so to find these guns and these maids
it's a very very tricky endeavor we got
two of them and we use them for our
division short you can see you can see
it in the video on our channel as well
as the video on Vsauce Channel the one
that everybody plays with that you're
constantly bugged me because I st. great
airsoft guns it's a shotgun right here
now you can find these at ebike these
are special shotguns that actually have
real loading shells that you load into
the shotgun and you fire it in and
Racquet tactical reload it's probably
the most gratifying airsoft going to use
on film say Jeff like a real shotgun
it's super cool and saves you a ton of
time doing VFX
now this guy has seen a lot of use over
the past year this is kind of our basic
sniper rifle we've been using a ton
unknown episodes and it's since been
modified with a little pipe holder for
an easy sling access point this guy is
what Gavin used in the fallout 4
slow-motion video so this is an L 87
right here it's a really junky gun but
for a while my dreams were that this has
become a nice airsoft gun because
generally speaking the longer your
barrel length inside your airsoft gun
the more accurate your shots this
bullpup design with having the mag back
here in the grip right here I mean that
you can have a compact gun with a really
long barrel now the AR platform that
just m4 is m16s and general variants
thereof are really nice for airsoft guns
you can see can work with a lot of the
parts interchange them so if something
breaks and you want to add on almost any
a our platforms interchangeable let's
put together for the division it has
this lighter gray look which just makes
it pop a little bit more to the eye and
has been tacked out with a laser pointer
a sight for grip a little guard to make
sure the bb's don't break your glass all
that good stuff now in inrush the
battlefield series that we did there's
four characters in each representing one
two classes from the games recon assault
support and engineering this is going to
be a potential other option for our
recon character no evike put this
together for us they did all the custom
paint work made it look really cool and
it never got used the reason is we use
this guys set so this is what our
character our Recon character action
used new styled after a green for con
specialist it's got suppressor cool
sights now the tricky thing was we had a
bunch of blank firing guns on Rush and
we need to get the airsoft equivalents
and make sure they look exactly the same
which is why we did use
sky because we didn't have a real
version of that this bad boy right here
that girl may be far more accurate
because this gun was used as the non
firing double for our Avery sniper
character and used to have a handmade
wooden flash suppressor on the front
with real guns you can just hold them up
and aim with the berry pinky calcic
Richard Brian let me shoot his Barrett
once it's pretty cool they're really
smooth they don't kick that much that's
not as present yeah m249 I think it's
the paratrooper variation of it because
has the extendable stock once again this
is one of the things we had to deal with
when shooting rush was that this is what
we had for blank firing guns we need to
get the airsoft gun they had the exact
stock design yeah it's pretty cool stock
design huh we have all these crazy guns
they all do really cool things they're
all very unique in their own way
but with all these hundreds of airsoft
guns I really picked out a certain
selection that I actually use myself a
real airsoft game the ones I think are
probably the best airsoft guns you can
go and you can trick out your guns make
them really nice and by that point it's
a pure custom machine it doesn't matter
where you come from but these are the
guys that have kept me up and running
ecology vision g418 reliable nice light
easy to carry doesn't break it's got a
mosfet inside which makes the trigger
response much quicker a little guard
here that has been broken once already
the sights about 80 bucks this is
probably the favorite this is the one
I've been using forever nice thing about
this is the battery stored in stock the
stock still folds up though even the
batteries are stored in it so you can
make it really compact by close range
fighting put this out for long range
fighting stock with an extend from there
nice little riser and red dot here so it
gets above the iron sights
my foregrip that turns into a bipod up a
little dusty right now if I'm doing a
close-quarters fight this is my go-to
AEG this is a knight's armament PDW made
by Lancer tactical now this gun is super
reliable in kicks are I mean the bb's
come out fast straight and they just
kept all that kinetic energy and
honestly when it comes to airsoft guns
reliability is the biggest thing for me
you're running around you're going to
fields I just I don't like tinkering
with guns for hours at a time dirt and
dust I play outdoors a bunch you know
you're running around the guns are
bumping into things getting banged up so
I just won't be quick access I want them
to work and I want them to shoot
straight now pistols pistol airsoft
games are where it's at makes the fights
up-close personal and tactical and
there's a lot more you can do with just
having good aim and good decisions I've
gone through a lot of their soft doses
they break all the time except for this
one and maybe I just got lucky or maybe
it's a damn good gun who knows but this
is a w/e 1911 for real classic real
basic it's the job done it's never
failed me I've had it for about four
years
Meg's only single stack so you don't get
a ton of rounds per pistol in this meg
your babies just form a single line I'm
okay with that I like this guy this is
one be many trouble in terrorist town
news we got through a lot of the airsoft
guns that we have we've gotten through
my favorites from the games at some
point you probably have Sam do his
favorites if you guys have some favorite
airsoft guns I'd love to hear what they
are below especially pistols have you
any recommendations something that's
super reliable shoot straight and like
you just never have to pop it off let me
know you guys are looking for airsoft
guns but check out evike pull disclosure
they sponsored us four years or still
with them for a reason they really
helped us out with good gear and they
don't make airsoft guns necessarily
they're a retailer they sell a bunch but
they have a website that has a ton of
videos they try to make in-depth
documentation on everything they have
there you can watch a bunch of stuff
there like the Newegg of airsoft if
you're looking at airsoft guns check
them out
[Music]